Speaker 1: Republicans are now going to
investigate the January 6th investigation.
What? Yeah, we knew they would do it. The last
Congress saw the House of Representatives January
6th Committee. That was a committee which
investigated the Trump riots. Republicans
for a long time have been saying the committee
is the problem. The committee has committed
wrongdoing. And now, as expected, there is going
to be an investigation of the investigation. NBC
News reports Republicans launch an investigation
into the January 6th committee that examined the
riot. Congressman Barry Loudermilk from Georgia
will lead the investigation and was accused by
the House's former January 6th panel of giving
tours of the Capitol in the days leading up to
the riot. So individuals whose connection to
the riots is at minimum raising some red flags
are going to be doing the investigating into the
very committee that looked at some of their own
actions. This is an infinite regression to some
degree, but it is also maybe one of the most bad
faith investigations that Republicans want to
take on. The article goes on to say many House
Republicans were vocal critics since the creation
of the January six committee. Yeah, we know
the inquiry seems to make good on lawmakers
campaign trail vows to investigate. The
investigators now understand this will go nowhere.
This is going to go absolutely nowhere. I know
that I get some of these emails from the right and
see some comments on the YouTube channel about,
oh, we're going to put we're going to put
Adam Schiff in prison for that January six
committee. Jamie Raskin is going to be locked up
for the weekend. No, they're not. Nobody's going
to be locked up. It was a completely reasonable,
well-organized. Well, it was actually one of the
best investigative endeavors that I've seen the
House of Representatives undertake in at least a
decade. But they need to virtue signal. They need
to show that we are going to do the thing and it
will sort of end with a fizz rather than a bang
and nothing will happen. A couple of other notes
about this CNN report, some additional details.
House Republicans plot new January 6th probes
despite internal backlash over Kevin McCarthy
giving Tucker Carlson footage. So this is the
background to Republicans saying we're going
to investigate that January 6th committee in
the background. Republicans are only raising new
reasons why they should be the ones investigated.
And most recently, it is Kevin McCarthy handing
over previously unreleased footage from the
January 6th Insurrection riot. Call it what you
Want to Tucker Carlson to Fox News propagandist
Tucker Carlson. We now know, of course, that
Tucker Carlson turned that around and used the
footage to try to claim falsely, by the way, that
the entire story we were told about January six
was wrong. Even many Republicans in responding
to Tucker Carlson's bogus narrative that he is
played out on national television, I believe
it was Monday and Tuesday of this week. Even
many Republicans have said Tucker's conclusions,
Tucker's narrative, based on the footage that he
aired, doesn't actually follow from the footage.
So this is the latest thing. It will probably end,
you know, to people like you and I. We see
this stuff and we say, wow. Humiliating.
Endless resources spent the virtue signaling
and the mouth flapping and the entire thing.
And of course, they come up with nothing. It's
like Durham Trump waiting around for months,
if not years. Durham Durham's going to expose
all the things Democrats know. Nothing came of
it. Nothing came of it. And that's why these
investigations are very loudly announced. And
then they end with a fizz because there's really
nothing there. If anything, we need a new January
6th committee investigating the alleged and
arguable Republican cover up of January 6th.
That even includes these recent things over the
last few months. What will actually happen as
the day to day and what confrontations will
there be or what would the hearings be like?
We'll just have to wait and see. But I am not a
betting man, but I would be willing to bet here.
Nothing substantive comes of the investigation
into the investigation. If you disagree with me,
if you think that the January six committee did
something wrong or whatever the case may be,
let me know in a comment. Let me know in an
email. I'd be interested in hearing from you.